[Music]
work for the expansion of area 15
continues and as we've reported as a
result there was a disability Center
that needed to close the center did find
a new location and as Victoria Saha
learned it was thanks to our generous
eight news now viewers who gave the
center some hope
it's heartbreaking for members of
progress Ive choices to be forced
and they eventually found a new place by
Jones and Twain and now they're making
up for lost time it's a full house again
for Progressive choices I miss these
guys when we were gone Marcus ullage has
been a member for more than two decades
this is our second home so you can
imagine how hard it was for Marcus when
his home was taken over by the owners of
area 15. when that place
closed down
I lost my family the center offers jobs
and various skills for adults with
intellectual disabilities when we first
did our report in January the future was
unclear for Progressive choices the fact
that it was such short notice it was
what made it really difficult Vice
President of Operations Michael Hogue
says the uncertainty wasn't good for
their members the camaraderie they build
with their peers not having that it has
an impact and the rush to find a new
place was hard but eight news now
viewers took action it was awesome we
had people that you know donated some
money and things like that so thank you
guys the channel That was amazing giving
members like Marcus a purpose again
we're back together again my life is
helping people so and I'm glad I'm back